[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat place ce matin à la
première audition de la commission d'
enquête sur la radicalisation islamiste
commission d' enquête lancée à la
demande du groupe l'est républicain au
sénat et qui a d'ailleurs pour
rapporteur la sénatrice lr jacqueline
eustache brinio qui s'est fait remarquer
ces dernières semaines pour avoir porté
la proposition de loi sur la neutralité
religieuse pour les accompagnants de
sorties scolaires
la présidente de sa commission d'enquêté
quant à elle la sénatrice rds nathalie
delattre
hier les sénateurs ont entamé leur cycle
d'auditions avec celle de youssef chiheb
professeur associé à l'université paris
xiii directeur de recherche au cnrs il a
fait un état des lieux très sombre sur
le sujet pour lui le processus de
radicalisation n'est pas nouveau lors de
son audition il est revenu sur le manque
de contrôle des prêches des imams les
problèmes que posent les circuits de
financement extérieur qui empêche le
développement d'un islam de france
l'islam politique est pour lui une
réalité et un filtre tous les facteurs
menaçant notre démocratie
un discours qui vous l'aurez compris est
plutôt classé à droite et qui n'a pas
manqué de faire réagir
à gauche certains sénateurs lui demande
d'ailleurs s'il ne faisait pas quelques
amalgames
mais tout de suite place aux échanges
qui se sont donc tenus hier au sénat
nous commençons donc aujourd'hui nos
travaux de commission denquête ainsi que
nous l'avons décidé lors de notre
réunion constitutive nous allons d'abord
procéder à l'audition d'experts
susceptibles d'éclairer notre
compréhension de ce sujet complexe
qu'est la radicalisation islamiste
nous avons donc sollicité le professeur
youssef schieb qui est professeur
associé à l'université paris xiii
directeur de recherche au centre
français de recherche sur le
renseignement qui est infime fang
spécialisés comme son nom l'indiqué sur
les questions de renseignement
vous êtes monsieur le professeur un
spécialiste de l'islam radical et du
communautarisme auquel vous avez
consacré de nombreux travaux donc tout
récemment un livre vous avez eu
l'amabilité de nous faire parvenir deux
documents
le premier est une
vous avez publié sous l'égide du centre
français de recherche sur le
renseignement sur le vocabulaire
islamique
le second était préparés spécialement
pour cette audition nous vous en
remercions il s'agit d'une synthèse du
plan d'action du gouvernement accompagné
de votre analyse qui figurent notamment
sous la forme d'une précieuse annie
annexes pardon sur l'islam radical
nous nous intéressons à la manière dont
l'islamisme a pénétré la société
française mais aussi la manière dont
celui ci affecte le vivre ensemble au
quotidien
j'espère que nos échanges nous
permettront d'aborder ces questions
longuement je vous indique que cette
audition sera diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du sénat il fera également
l'objet d'un compte rendu publié
enfin je rappelle pour la forme mais
pour le fond aussi qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission denquête
seraient passibles des peines prévues
aux articles 434 13 4 134 14 et 434 15
du code pénal je vous invite sa a prêté
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité
lever la main droite s'il vous plaît et
dit je le jure je le jure madame la
présidente je vous remercie
alors si vous voulez bien monsieur le
professeur vous pourriez en quelques
minutes faire une brève présentation
liminaire notamment sur votre définition
de l'islamisme et du communautarisme au
coeur de vos travaux sur la sémantique
vous avez pu mener et votre retour sur
le plan d'action contre la
radicalisation et le terrorisme où vous
nous avez fait parvenir donc le
catalogue conséquent du gouvernement et
dictées en 2016 et est le premier bilan
que vous en tirez je vous poserai
quelques questions puis ensuite je
passerai la parole à madame la
rapporteure puis à mesdames et messieurs
les commissaires pour vous poser des
questions nous vous écoutons monsieur le
professeur comme la présidente
je vous remercie de m'avoir conviés à
cette audition pour parler d'un sujet
d'actualité un sujet qui s'ancre h dans
l'associé de notre société et qui
constitue désormais une menace pour la
république
ces valeurs et principalement la laïcité
et le vivre ensemble
je voulais ouvrir une parenthèse
rapidement pour rendre aussi hommage à
nos soldats qui sont morts en europe et
en opérations extérieures
c'est dire que la menace est à la fois
internationale mais hélas par le biais
de la radicalisation est devenu aussi
une menace endogène prédominante dont il
faut tenir compte et qu'il faut plus se
voiler la face mais qu'il faut
l'affronter avec courage et
détermination
je tiens à dire aussi que j'ai passé 2
septembre 2015 à cet endroit 2017
j'étais chargé de mission au ministère
de l'intérieur au sein du service
central du renseignement territoriale et
à ce titre il ya certaines informations
qui sont classés auquel donc je vais pas
m'étaler mai et toutes les informations
que je vais mettre à votre disposition
100 des recherches dit en milieu ouvert
c'est-à-dire accessible sur internet et
le recoupement des la communauté des
chercheurs et des comités de
renseignement alors tout d'abord je
voudrais faire un bref rappel à
l'histoire puisque je vous ai soumis à
envoyer par mais donc les la matière
auquel vous avez fait allusion tout à
l'heure je préfère avec votre permission
parler du contexte vu par l
universitaire et par un spécialiste
entre guillemets du problème alors la
première des choses c'est que nous avons
durant près de trente ans en france
constituer un modèle de régulation
sociale sociétale et territoriales
ambigu qui s'est retournée contre
certains élus locaux et contre la
république par effet domino
la première étant que le processus de
radicalisation n'est pas nouveau mais
qui est là simplement changer de
sémantique comme l'a rappelé madame la
présidente
ce sont les frères barbu qui sont vient
remplacer les confrères dans la version
socialiste en tout cas des années de
madame martine aubry sous forme d'une
autorégulation du vivre ensemble mais
qui devient de plus en plus ce qui est
de plus en plus a été instrumentalisé
par les islamistes deuxième observation
que je voulais apporter c'est
l'externalisation de la gestion du culte
musulman aux états tiers hors france en
particulier au maghreb l'âge cette
gestion / de forme d'abord le
financement est ensuite l'envoi d' imam
pour prêcher et diriger les mosquées le
financement et les néo tracé n'est
dépensée dans ce qui pour quoi il était
attribuée également des agréments
accordés par nos services de préfecture
aux associations culturelles qui s'est
avéré avec le temps qu'il suffit juste
d'enlever le r pour comprendre leur
réalité que 100 des associations
cultuelles
ils n'ont pas culturelle des cours
d'arabisation comme un cheval de troie
pour l'islamisation des enfants et des
mineurs
un calendrier culturel et événementiel
organisé en arrière-plan par les
consulats pour freiner le processus
d'intégration et d'assimilation et donc
là aussi c'est un sujet très sensible
c'est une forme d'ingérence masqué qui
heurte le processus au qui bloque le
processus d'intégration d'assimilation
républicaine un double langage également
des élus l'écho de locaux par dont deux
issus de l'immigration entre
l'appartenance aux valeurs de la
république sont publiques et leurs
allégeances alors sources soient leurs
origines que sont les pays où son
ni leurs parents leurs grands parents le
pullulement des salles de prières vous
vous permettez de s'attarder quelques
secondes pour faire la nuance entre les
mosquées et les salles de prière les
salles de prière sans le véritable
laboratoire de la production de la
radicalisation
sans le véritable laboratoire de
l'apologie du jihadisme et du terrorisme
alors que les mosquées et sans plus ou
moins contrôlée dès lors il ya un
recteur ou les imams fonctionnaires
entre guillemets qui viennent des pays
tiers sans tenue par une espèce de
retenue entre guillemets le roland bugat
également du cfcm conseil français du
culte musulman qui n'a jamais été clair
sur les sa position vis-à-vis des
valeurs cardinales de la république dans
l'espèce la laïcité en premier lieu la
prédominance de la langue arabe dans les
prêches et dans les mosquées donc nous
n'avons pas l'islam français
malheureusement nous avons un islam en
france si on est encore dans cette
logique a été décrit décrié par monsieur
près de l'ancien président de la
république monsieur nicolas sarkozy
force de constater l'année qu'elle avait
anticipé l'histoire en qualifiant
l'islam en france et non pas l'islam de
france par l'arabité en tout cas
la doctrine de l'état manière générale
durant toutes ces années étaient
concentrés sur la lutte contre la
délinquance de voie publique et le
sentiment d'insécurité et qu'il
considérait que la radicalisation était
plus un fantasme des milieux
intellectuels et des universitaires
jusqu'à ce que nous ont été rattrapés
par l'histoire
malheureusement par les attentats il ya
aussi il faut rappeler l'échec de la
politique de la ville malgré le fait
qu'en qu'on a dépensé des milliars
particulièrement le plan de monsieur
borloo pour la rénovation urbaine qui a
tenté de roquettes de récupérer ces
fameux territoires perdus de la
république
mais l'effort de constater que la
république à son tour a raté son rendez
vous avec l'histoire sur les 4 eacom
j'ai publiés dans un article les quatre
i l'islam en france l'immigration en
france
l'intégration en france l'identité
française
ce sont quatre éléments fondamentaux
fondamentaux quand été mis de côté dans
le processus de régulation de ces
territoires
il ya également les services de
renseignements n'ont cessé d'alerter les
autorités du gouvernement sur la
mobilité de nos concitoyens pour motifs
religieux à l'étranger des milliers
partent chaque année dans des mares case
c'est à dire des centres islamiques
spécifique au maghreb au moyen-orient en
egypte au yémen avant bien sûr le
déclenchement du printemps arabe et des
leurs autour personne ne s'est posé la
question qu'est ce qui était en train de
faire dans ces lieux crisogène et dans
ces lieux deux et deux réacteurs de
l'islam radical
la libre circulation des imams et des
prêcheurs de haine qui viennent souvent
dans notre pays ce que j'ai publié dans
ce livre les théoriciens de l'islam
radical quand j'étais au ministère de
l'intérieur 60 prédicateur
jouissent d'une totale liberté alors
qu'eux ils déversent de l'acide et des
matières corrosif sur la france enfin la
lourdeur et l' entrave aux procédures
d'expulsion des imams qui prêchent de la
haine dans les mosquées
j'ouvre une parenthèse j'ai travaillé
pendant six mois six mois où j'ai passé
plus des milliers d'heures des gouttes
pour traduire ses prêts sur la de
l'arabe vers le français
pour comprendre ce langage polysémique
métaphorique très complexe et qui est
bien sûr lycée et police et quand elle
est en français mais dense avait eu dans
un version originale en arabe c'est un
langage extrêmement corrosif et il a
fallu six mois pour expulser un seul
imam alors que dans le viseur des crt en
tout cas il y en avait eu plus d'une
centaine qui devait quitter le
territoire national
la multiplication également des sites
islamiques en total d'unités qui déverse
ou qui verse dans l'apologie du
terrorisme et qui déconstruit surtout
les valeurs de la république
la prolifération du commerce
communautaire et de l'économie halal qui
est le principal enjeu aussi de l'islam
radical dans ce territoire et enfin en
tant qu'universitaire la aux gens s'ils
à paris xiii tous les vendredis je ne
sais pas si je suis dans une université
si je suis dans une mosquée les filles
et jeunes filles en basser qui porte un
regard ostentatoire non seulement le
voile islamique mais carrément leur
hijab est le narrateur et personne ne
peut changer cette réalité alors qu'il
est devient de plus en plus visible
alors pendant toute cette période l'état
avec une seule doctrine quand je les
remplis tout à l'heure c'est se pencher
sur la lutte contre les violences
urbaines jalis autrefois et la
rénovation urbaine et en laisser de côté
ce troisième chapitre qui le plus
dangereux qui le traitement de l'islam
radical
alors comment c'était c'est l'islam qui
s'est développée au sein de nos
territoires
tout d'abord parce que les états tiers
et j'insiste sur cette information
renvoi des imams qui sont imbibés de
doctrine salafiste ou des frères
musulmans ou du wahhabisme en toute
impunité sans aucun filtre j'avais dire
filtre cultuelle ce par référence au
cfcm au filtre légale par rapport à nos
autorités de voir d'or ne parle or leur
cv alors donc il n'ya pas de causalité
en réalité il n'y a pas de rapport de
causalité entre radicalisation et crise
périurbaines aux crises dans les
banlieues aux crises sociales tant que
un paradigme qu'il faut plus nous mettre
ensemble mais nous sommes en face à la
résurgence d'une nouvelle identité une
nouvelle conflictuelle ite et surtout un
nouveau rapport de force entre les
islamistes et la laïcité
leur objectif suprême c'est la
déconstruction de la laïcité c'est de
faire de notre pays un pays comme le
modèle anglo saxon américain où le monde
et la britannique hall 1 où la pratique
ou sont au douar de la religion n'est
pas encadrée par la loi
pendant tout ce temps on a essayé aussi
de répondre à des questions qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un radicaliser et bien
qu'est ce que c'est que la radicale
a sion fort de constater en
travailleront pardon sur des centaines
et des centaines de notes de service on
s'est rendu compte qu'il n'y a pas de
profil type d'un radicalisme et c'est là
tout le danger c'est l'imprévisibilité
de 1000 personnes radicaliser à passer à
l'acte
je voudrais pour ne pas trop vous
ennuyer avec elle c'est cette analyse
ont recommandé et profiter de cette
occasion qui m'a été donné devant les
suit la nation pour vous faire quelques
propositions innovantes efficace et qui
n'ont jamais été prises en compte par ce
qu'il dépasse le champ juridique il
empiète sur le politique
la première il faut couper les
financements le financement étranger de
l'islam de france
je suis pas juriste mais c'est une
urgence
coupez la cogestion du fait religieux en
france
en redéfinissant des relations claires
avec les pays du maghreb et le
moyen-orient sortir des politiquement
correct par rapport dans nos relations
avec les pays du golfe notamment
l'arabie saoudite et le qatar l'arabie
saoudite exporte le wahhabisme et le
qatar ils financent l'islamisme pour ne
pas dire autre chose en dehors du de la
caricature qu'ils financent le péché
introduire l'islamologie comme
discipline universitaire pour soustraire
l'islam de l'emprise des prédicateurs il
est peut-être venu le temps de se mettre
d'accord que c'est une communauté de 5,6
millions kit qu'il tanqueray en france
doit être aussi encadré au niveau
éthique et au niveau scientifique par
rapport à l'or q que tous leurs
convictions religieuses
contrôler cette mobilité des jeunes qui
part dans la nature sous forme d'origine
migration sous forme de omra je rappelle
que le qatar finances à peu près un
millier de omra s'avère le petit
pèlerinage chaque année avec un critère
discriminatoire très très alarmant c'est
la cible ce sont les convertis et donc
la nouvelle dimension aussi ces fameux
convertis qui sont cooptés par le qatar
pour aller effectuer le petit pèlerinage
consolidé renforcer le partenariat avec
les pays du maghreb notamment sur cette
question quant à l'individu par maghreb
et serait bien dès son retour en france
qu'en face à des briefings pour savoir
où il était j'ai identifié les points au
maroc en algérie en tunisie en egypte au
yémen les points il ya deux cent
quatorze marquez c'est-à-dire centre
islamistes ou ce forum c'est jean
l'islam radical et de leur retour donc
sans tranquille personne ne leur pose
des questions
je voudrais aussi vous demander de bien
vouloir réfléchir sur les conditions
d'attribution d'agrément aux
associations ces associations dans leur
quasi totalité se présente comme
association d'amitié franco marocaine
franco algérienne de développement
durable en réalité ce sont des
associations qui sont cultuel et ce sont
eux qui organisent et qui ont une
emprise sur cinq des deux salles de
prière et une fille née sur les
territoires islamisée je pense que
l'ensemble de ces mesures doivent
aboutir à une redéfinition de l'islam en
france l'islam en france est un échec
les slam de france est une illusion il
faute à l'islam français et j'entends
par anis la france ait un contrôle total
de son financement
il faut que la france récupère entre
guillemets sa souverainté du fait de se
couper de ses prédicateurs de six imams
qui viennent et c'est tout le paradoxe
de la laïcité où on se tire une balle
dans le pied
on ne finance pas le culte mais on
l'accepté finances extérieures on
finance pas les imams mais on importe
des imams l'extérieur et on subit la
cogestion avec tous ses dégâts
collatéraux que sont l'islam radical
enfin redéfinir aussi la mission du cfcm
pardonnez moi l'expression faire du
ménage au sein de cette institution qui
en fin de compte in et une nounou est
une structure d'un flux ans qui présente
publiquement dans des instances leur
allégeance à des états tiers et non pas
d'abord à la république il faut
que cet instant soit représentative
démocratiques transparentes et laïque et
j'insiste sur ce terme dans l'état
actuel des choses et ne l'est pas c'est
un c'est un conseil qui s'exporte comme
modèle mais dans les autres pays il ya
la prévalence la religion sur les
valeurs de la république
je souhaite également et j'en termine
que les enfants de la république qui ont
été influencés par les trois courants
loi haby le salafisme et les frères
musulmans
l'état doit construire un contre
discours de thé radicalisation je
rappelle que ça a été déjà entamé ce
processus
quand certains opportunistes ont profité
de l'eau j'allais dire de la détresse de
l'état dans le pic d'activité terroriste
pour présenter des des protocoles de
déradicalisation alors qu'on est encore
en train de se poser qu'est ce que c'est
que la radicalisation alors que d'autres
ils ont déjà anticipé par par
opportunisme donc les les universitaires
doivent prendre toute leur place
les centres de recherche doivent prendre
toute leur place aussi pour porter
assistance technique à nos élus aux élus
de la république pour finaliser des
projets de lois qui encadrent cet islam
entre guillemets informel pour ne pas
dire sauvage je vous remercie madame la
présidente
merci professeur de ce brillant exposé
que vous avez dû condenser puisque nous
avons une audition d'une heure il nous
reste 35 minutes pour donner la parole à
l'ensemble je poserai quelques questions
puis passerelle
la parole très vite à notre rapporteur
dans vos propos effectivement vous
parlez d'un état qui doit construire un
contre discours jeu j'aurai une première
question comment le monde musulman
perçoit la radicalisation
comment ceux qui exercent un islam dit
normal son sens radicalisme perçoivent
cette radicalisation est ce qu'il ya une
condamnation ferme au sein des
institutions du culte musulman musulmans
en france et à l'étranger se
contredisent court quand vous dites que
c'est l'état qui doit le construire ne
doit-il pas déjà être construit au sein
de l'islam qui doit aussi porter en son
sens est ce combat contre la
radicalisation
y at il des personnalités d'autorité de
l'islam en france qui pourrait faire
consensus autour de ce contre discours
et puis par rapport aux documents que
vous nous aviez envoyé
vous parlez d'une laïcité rénové est ce
que vous souhaitez faire évoluer évoluer
la loi de 1905 ou moins je vois
effectivement dans vos propos et je
serai je convergent vers cette idée de
dire que la problématique n'est pas 1905
mai 1901 puisque effectivement sous
couvert de culturel et bien c'est
souvent très souvent de plus en plus
souvent du cultuel donc comment arrivé
effectivement à faire évoluer un
monument qui est la loi de 1901 est
effectivement est ce que ce n'est pas
privé une certaine liberté
d'autres associations qui n'en font pas
un détournement de ce type là donc
comment vous appréhendez effectivement
ce dossier là et puis vous parlez des
prêches en français dans les mosquées
ça c'est bon pour aujourd'hui mais
demain déjà et la génération du 4.0
les images seront portatif c'est à dire
que tout appartement deviendra une salle
de prière avec des prêches dans des
langues étrangères que nous n'arriverons
pas à peut-être contrôle et donc quelles
sont vos préconisations lucien en la
matière voilà merci est ce que vous
répondez déjà cette première vague
peut-être et puis ensuite madame le
rapporteur où tu veux compléter dans la
première vague et ensuite je donnerai la
parole à madame la rapportant merci
merci madame la présidente
alors pour ce qui est de la production
de contre-discours contre la
radicalisation
je crois et j'assume mes propos que ceux
qui en ont la charge du culte musulman
les membres du cfcm ne sont pas
habilités à le faire sont pas habilités
à le faire d'abord de par leur cursus de
leur parcours
deuxièmement de par le niveau
d'allégeance qu'ils envisageaient de
leur état d'origine je rappelle que le
cfcm n'ai qu'un conseil qui représente
aussi des influences marocaine
algérienne égyptien autres un turc
autres et donc on ne peut pas confier la
production d'un discours de la contre
discours qui est rationnel qui est laïc
à des gens qui ne le sont pas donc
j'aime et des réserves
madame la présidente avec votre
permission de confier ça à ces considère
qu'ils sont pas en capacité de prendre
du recul et de d'être conscient qu'on
est en france qu'on n'est pas ou mal gré
ce qui nous renvoie à la suite de votre
question comment est perçu là la
radicalisation
j'ai posé cette question j'ai travaillé
sur cette question le mot radicalise on
est impropre
il n'existe pas dans le vocabulaire de
ces états pour une raison simple dire
que ce sont des états non laïque qu'il
n'y a pas de dichotomie entre pouvoirs
temporels religieux donc considère que
la france et je cite je partage pas mais
je cite là la france est dans une auto
dorcy laïque et du coup donc il ya choc
des dogmes d'un côté le dogme salafistes
religieux et de l'autre côté le togolais
les sites m
deuxièmement ces pays combattre
combattent le terrorisme est pas la
radicalisation le terrorisme avec des
manières c'est rose parfois par des
procédés illégaux mais il cherche avant
tout l'efficacité mais il n'y a pas de
programme sont de protocole qui utilise
le mot radicalisation est ce qu'on
considère que c'est un problème propre à
la france elles ont en général
alors pour la laïcité rénové j'entends
par là qu'il est venu le temps qu'on
mène une réflexion sur quelles sont les
modalités d'inclusion de l'islam
français et de leurs temporalités
c'est à dire avant la loi 1904-1905 y
avait pas d' islam en france
comment doit-on aller vers la prise en
compte de cette mutation sociétale et
culturelle très importante de notre pays
sont renoncer aux valeurs cardinales de
la laïcité je suis très clair là-dessus
il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
c'est à l'islam de s'adapter à la
laïcité et non le contraire
et d'ailleurs beaucoup de musulmans en
france par les sondages s'y adapte donc
la demande des musulmans en france
c'est juste de ne pas essentiel is et
l'islam de ne pas discriminer islam dont
les débats qu'ils soient politiques ou
médiatiques mais en revanche et
souscrivent tous aux valeurs de la
république
autrement dit elle est la phrase mais
des dit plusieurs fois les musulmans
comme les français et moi même bien
entendu au nez islamistes fob j'aimerais
introduire ce mot dans le vocabulaire
en france on y islamistes forment mais
on n'est pas islamophobe leur
islamophobie c'est à contre sens
sémantique ça n'existe
je sais pas qui c'est qui l'a inventé
mais en tout cas il y à une islamiste
aux phobies sur laquelle il ya un
consensus entre les musulmans entre les
français de confession musulmane et le
français tour
je rappelle enfin que selon les
dernières statistiques que plus de 60
millions pour cent des musulmans de
france sont laïques et qui sont
malheureusement pas représentée par
sedan ce fameux cfcm qui est un condensé
d'orthodoxes et de et de religieux enfin
pour le français pour le prêche en
français en langue française
ça se fait maintenant mais il ya une
véritable technique de tarija de
dissimulation qui se cache derrière ces
choses là
chaque vendredi je j'écoute à radio
radio orient qui est transmis en direct
le prêche de la grande mosquée j'aime
paris je suis parfaitement j'ai eu la
chance d'être arabophone donc je
comprends très bien la langue arabe donc
la traduction du prêche du français et
on n'est pas le même le prêche en
français et aseptisée et les politiser
et les vider de certains mots qui en un
sens particulier mais dans la version
originale en arabe et les prêcher quand
même avec un niveau 2 de violence et de
radicalité quand même qu'il faut quand
il faut tenir compte toutes les prêches
que j'ai traduit tu puisses traduit par
don quand j'étais service central des
renseignements territoriale m'ont
confirmé ce paradigme c'est que c'est
une technique de communication ils n'ont
pas un prêche en soi et donc il faut
être vigilant
d'où le fait que je considère aussi pour
des raisons de de lutte contre la
discrimination en lait en france en les
français nos enfants sont français
s'ils veulent aller à la mosquée pour
qu'on leur parle et non qu'ils
comprennent pas quid des autres
communautés intra musulmanes qui sont
les comités du sahel d'afrique qui sont
pas arabophone déjà en soi ces
salafistes s'inscrit dans une dans un
processus de discrimination alors qu'il
ne cesse de le rappeler qu'ils sont
discriminés ici ou là parce qu'ils
portent le hidjab ou pas donc il faut
être clair sur cette question là
nous avons la capacité si nous avons
formé des imams à parler en français si
de parler d'eux le prince badr de
d'organiser le prêche en langue
française que tout le monde comprenne la
même chose je parlais tout à l'heure de
deux salles de prière
moi je crois que c'était des élus ces
questions très importantes
il ya un moment il faut arrêter de
troquer la paix sociale avec les
communautés les mosquées sont gérés et
contrôlés par les services de
renseignement il ya un protocole haddock
qui permet de mieux les contrôler lahoud
sont faibles
c'est dans les salles de mosquée parce
qu'il s'adonne révélé ça de pris à part
dont parce qu'il n'ya pas plus facile
pour une pour quelqu'un de concept de
louer un ancien local un hangar quelque
part dans une zone industrielle
donc ça ça rabaisse même l'islam en tant
que tel d'être dans des lieux ans quasi
insalubre mais en même temps ça
échappent aux radars des renseignements
il ya quand même plus de sur les les
1000 troisième 1300 salle de prière
et il faut aussi appliquer ce qui
s'applique dans les pays musulmans
c'est une banalité tels que i mosquée
est ouverte cinq fois par jour
juste le temps du culte sopfeu c'est le
pria matin midi l'après midi le coucher
de soleil et de la nuit
après c'est fermé or les salafistes
s'installe entre des prières ou les
vieux chibanis parts et là le l'espace
est vide c'est là on commence à faire
non pas du prêche de la prière mais des
séminaires et c'est là où il faut
peut-être légiférer que ce lieu de culte
doit être fermé dès lors au la prière
est terminée une dernière chose pour
revenir à la laïcité c'est que la france
avait délégué en quelque sorte au maroc
la formation des imams je suis parti au
maroc ce que je suis originaire du maroc
et j'ai demandé à mes collègues qui sont
dans cet institut de me donner le module
fallen la maquette le programme il n'y a
pas une matière qui fait allusion à
l'histoire livre de france il n'y a pas
une matière qui fait l'histoire aux
institutions de la république et plus
grave encore le mot laïcité lit
quasiment à confiner dans dans des
définitions vague qu'il est en gros
c'est dé la france était déchristianisée
et maintenant on veut d islamiser la
france donc on doit aussi revoir au
niveau de relation les affaires
étrangères doivent revoir cette matière
de mettre un contenu de mettre un
contrôle et pourquoi pas de détacher
quelqu'un de france pour aller veiller à
ce que ces futurs imams qui vont en
venir en toute légalité viennent avec un
cursus qui prenne en compte nos
institutions notre histoire et la
laïcité
merci de vos réponses précises je vais
passer la parole maintenant à notre
rapporteur qui ne le stage brignon merci
merci monsieur le professeur pour toutes
tout voilà vos propos je pense que en
tout cas moi j'en partage un certain
nombre je vais aussi parce que vous n'en
avez pas parlé dire que dans notre pays
malheureusement quand on dénonce les
excès les à l'islamisme et je parle pas
des musulmans je parlais des amis sme on
peut être menacée
comme vous pouvez l'être menacés comme
des journalistes sont menacés comme un
certain nombre de militants laïcs
peuvent être menacés comme certains
apostats peut être menacée ici dans
notre pays parce que je parle bien ici
même les apostats en france sont
menacées
je pense que on peut pas lier non plus
et moi je voulais aller un petit peu
plus loin sur vous a fait des
propositions fort intéressante on en
rediscute on en débattra mais moi
j'aurai peut-être plus loin est ce que
vous ne pensez pas aussi que certaines
organisations que certaines associations
bien infiltré par les frères musulmans
et les salafistes qui ont effectivement
qui bénéficie d'argent public et qui
ouvertement menace la république
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il menace
aujourd'hui notre démocratie et qu'il
conviendrait de trouver des textes pour
les dissoudre parce que est ce que vous
ne pensez pas que un certain nombre
d'entre ces associations où ces
organismes aujourd'hui menace notre
démocratie est ce que c'est une question
est ce que c'est
bon voilà un point de vue peut-être
excessif ou est ce que c'est une réalité
en tout cas je vous remercie aussi
d'avoir expliqué que les questions liées
à cette cet islamisme dont on parle
aujourd'hui n'est pas lié aux attentats
parce que c'est vrai que nous la france
a été bousculé en 2012 puis fortement
depuis 2015 mais que ces questions que
nous nous posons aujourd'hui plus
ouvertement parce que les atomes lieu on
se les pose est est on devait se l'est
posée depuis
bien longtemps et bien avant les
attentats on ne peut pas dire que c'est
les attentats qui ont apporté cette
réflexion que nous menons aujourd'hui
mais que nous aurions peut-être dû je ne
sais pas si c'est votre analyse cela
posait bien avant merci madame à porter
donc je vais essayer de répondre
rapidement à vos interrogations la
première des choses c'est que pour ce
qui est de la menace si j'ai accepté de
venir ici je vous en remercie c'est pour
acter cet acte et subit la montre pour
me protéger
parce que je reçois des mails et des
menaces mais alors à longueur de journée
parce que j'ai des lancers dont dans ce
livre les 60 prédicateur qui viennent en
france et qui déversent
c'est ce présent dans notre pays je
crois aujourd'hui que les musulmans ou
ceux qui s'amusent
elle s'assigne comme tel et qui est
adhèrent aux valeurs de la république
sont menacés dans leur intégrité
physique et aussi dans leur liberté de
circulation
j'ai reçu plusieurs mails de certains
pays où je suis interdit de séjour
l'arabie saoudite le qatar l'egypte le
yémen la mauritanie l'algérie le seul
pays qui me laisse encore rentrée si le
maroc c'est parce que je suis bi
national sinon ils n'ont pas du tout
apprécié que j'ai écrit que parmi les
radicaux il ya des marocains
deuxièmement je crois que l'islam
politique en réalité n'est pas un
fantasme non plus c'est une réalité
les frères musulmans en france sont en
train de s'installer il ya des enquêtes
qu'il a menées au cf2r qui montre
aujourd'hui est un filtre y compris les
corps intermédiaires
ils sont en train d'infiltrer de grandes
entreprises il suffit de regarder de
prendre une soixantaine de lignes de la
ratp sûr qu'on a observé pendant six
mois et on voit le profil type de
lentille salafistes qui est conducteur
du bus et que le vendredi si vous voulez
la sénateur je conviens certaines lignes
vous voyez que vendredi entre 12h30 et
13h30 ya aucun bus qui circulent parce
qu'ils sont tous en train de faire la
prière et cela est inadmissible et sont
en train aussi d'infiltrer les
universités
contrairement salafistes qui s'intéresse
aux individus défavorablement connu par
les services de police
les frères musulmans s'intéresse à bac
+5 leur réservoir
ce sont des universités parce que ça
fait partie de leur doctrine infiltrer
les corps intermédiaires infiltrer les
grands entreprises les universités plus
tard l'armée et renverser le régime de
l'intérieur c'était le modèle égyptien
qui était appliqué avec me more si donc
il faut faire très attention et que
j'entends dans les médias on parle du
communautarisme
ce mot peut être à force de de le verser
à toutes les a toutes les sauces pas si
on tente pas de l'ouest y pression n'a
pas de sens le communautarisme est une
conséquence ils n'ont pas un choix il ya
des gens qui vivent dans ces territoires
le communautarisme parce qu'ils sont
confinés par des politiques publiques de
type sont d'éducation prioritaire parce
que les hlm non n'attire pas forcément
les classes moyennes attire pas mais nos
compatriotes de type européen
donc il ya des gens qui veulent
soustraire à ces ghettos entre
guillemets mais qui n'en peuvent pas
pour des raisons de coût en revanche en
revanche islam politique d'une réalité
on a fait aussi des études et des
enquêtes on a vu que pendant les
dernières des élections présidentielle
et législatives et je serai très
attentif aux municipales que monsieur je
le dis avec toute la la responsabilité
que beaucoup de musulmans ont voté pour
monsieur emmanuel macron et que cet
islam politique qui est en train de
s'infiltrer doucement parce que c'était
ce nouveau un nouvel espace politique
qui est la république aux marches en
fait et les parties de rides qui n'a pas
de d'ancrage territorial qui n'a pas
d'ancrage dans l'histoire donc le vote
des minorités musulmanes s'oriente vers
ces espaces politiques non ancré dans
l'encré dans les territoires est ce que
j'appelle hybride
les frères musulmans monsieur tariq
ramadan quand il vient en france
j'ai toujours été heurtée pourquoi avec
tout ce qu'il a dit tout ce qu'il dit
qu'on le laisse encore le droit de
rentrer sur notre territoire
je rappelle qu'il est étranger il n'est
pas français
et pour finir je crois que notre
démocratie est menacée par plusieurs
conflits qu'tu alité par plusieurs
radicalité mais celle ci qui est propre
à l'islam doit être prise au sérieux
ce que ce sont des gens qui travaillent
sur le thon géologique ils ne sont pas
dans une temporalité de 3,4 en mai
construit considère que la fécondité
intrinsèque à la communauté musulmane
est un facteur exponentielle pour la
masse électorale jusqu'à jo d athènes la
masse critique ils peuvent constituer un
parti politique qui portera pas le nom d
islam de france où les musulmans de
france
certainement pas quand on voit tous les
partis politiques qui sont au pouvoir
dans les pays arabes
il porte au maroc c'est le parti de
justice et du développement en tunisie
ennahda renaissance en mauritanie
attawassoul être en phase avec son temps
donc ce sont des gens qui qui savent
très bien utiliser la sémantique
politique pour ne pas s'afficher comme
tel mais ils ont dans leur projet la
volonté de construire un à défaut d'un
parti politique en tout cas un gisement
électorale très important pour négocier
des choses avec la république et je
crains que leur première à d'orience
c'est la laïcité de où l'intérêt ou
l'urgence peut-être de une bonne fois
pour toutes qu'on définit ce que c'est
que la laïcité version 21e siècle en
2020 qu'est ce que c'est que la laïcité
feuille de route pour la république pour
les dizaines quarantaine d'années qui
viennent et qu'on laisse pas des brèches
pour les uns ou les autres pour faire
valoir des choses
merci de votre nouveau réponse j'ai cinq
collections donc demandé la parole je
vais peut-être prendre deux par deux
pour essayer d'aller plus vite
nathalie goulet puis ensuite rachid tu
es mal mais bon oui mal à la présidence
et monsieur le professeur nous avons
commis dans cette maison un rapport sur
l'islam de france valises de l'islam en
france à l'islam de france où on va
beaucoup plus loin que vous puisque nous
on veut la fin des imams détachées et la
fin de la formation des imams à
l'étranger donc il n'est même pas
question de d'envoyer un professeur là
nous on veut couper avec l'imam né avec
l'islam des consulats bon la première
chose la deuxième chose sur le
financement j'ai deux observations la
première fois la première c'est que le
sénat a voté trois fois l'alignement du
statut financier des associations 1900 à
1950 devant la présidente donc on n'a
pas du tout ce sujet nous et pas du tout
inconnu qu'il est jamais arrivé jusqu'à
l'assemblée nationale mais qu'on a une
règle dans la république c'est l'égalité
de tous devant la loi donc le jour où on
refusera les les financements étrangers
pour les musulmans de france il faudra
aussi empêcher monsieur poutine de
construire sa cathédrale
c'est comme ça donc et les financements
sont absolument tracé traque fin ils
travaillent donc on a aussi un sujet là
dessus moi je voudrais vous vous
interrogez parce que le temps nous est
compté mais mais j'aurais bien de très
nombreuses observations on a vu les
écoles de formation au maroc on avait
aussi été visité l'école de formation en
algérie et notre rapport contient de ce
point de vue là des préconisations
précisément parce qu'on avait un islam
qui était hors contexte français voilà
donc nous on aller beaucoup plus loin
que vous nous on veut on veut couper
avec limal et l'islam des consulats et
former les imams en france et donc la
question que je vais vous poser en
dehors de mille et une observation que
j'aurai à faire c'est quel est votre
diagnostic pour former des imams en
france
je recherche
on va prendre d'abord la question de
rachid tu es mal merci donc c'était
intéressant après jeu autant je peux
partager une grande partie de
propositions autant je pense que sur
votre explication bien que de
contradictions quand même et je vais pas
bon donc à deux endroits où je suis
peut-être d'abord je pense que
l'important est d'ailleurs vous l'avez
dit mais c'est une décontraction
comparaître français je mens je pense
qu'il est important notre commission
denquête c'est qu'on est bien les bons
mots au bon moment au bon endroit
dire que si on peut pas faire ces
amendes et on est sûr
ce qui sans d'abord être sur le
développement de la radicalisation
islamique et les moines à combattre
parce que soit enfin rapport sur l'islam
de france faisons le vraiment
sérieusement tu crois qu'il a été fait
là j'ai le sentiment qu'on a deux buts à
l'heure des vraies réponses mais on
mélange beaucoup de notions d'ailleurs
si je peux me permettre
les territoires perdus de la république
je vous rassure tous et l'appliquent qui
les a perdus parce qu' elle n'est pas
présente attention là aussi je crois que
c'est un truc qu'on le dit souvent mais
amende et je crois que moi c'est dans
l'autre sens qu'il ferait des choses et
après sur sur la question de la vous
avez beaucoup parlé de la question de
l'islam est encore une fois moi je
partage ce que vous dite madame boulet
sur le fait d'avoir un islam de france
effectivement il faut arrêter le
financement des consulats des pays
étrangers que ce soit dans la formation
etc
ha ça c'est le problème c'est qu'on le
dit depuis très longtemps et on le met
gm en application et je crois que
là-dessus vous pouvez tous d'accord pas
tous d'accord sur la cité faisons pas
son nom de découvrir la france a cette
chance d'être un pays laïc mais nous
sommes peu dans le monde à être un état
laïc donc des autres pays soit pas l'aï
que le cfcm sa palette j'en veux dire
oui bah parce qu'en fait c'est pas leur
choix
les autres pays ne sont pas donc la
laïcité nous la pratiquons il faut la
pratiquer que de 7 cm soit pas laïque
jean veut dire aucune instance
religieuse n'est par définition laïque
puisque par définition elle organise un
qte
donc voilà donc sur le reste moi je suis
assez par contre je suis moi je suis
opposé à l'histoire de notre histoire de
laïcité rénové parce que je crois que
c'est ouvrir une brèche dans la
république qui seraient dévastatrices
pages tout d'abord après et vous avez
tous les débats 1 avec toutes les
religions qui est donc une ambition
c'est de retirer la laïcité moi je pense
qu'il faut au contraire devenir bon là
dessus après si je verrai de l'année
dernière remarque j'ai pas spécialement
de questions mais sur vite s'il faut pas
faire parler d' islamophobie
vous avez raison moi aussi j'ai eu droit
d'ailleurs un bon lot d'insultés de
menaces quand je dis cela mais l'islam
l'islamo phobie hectares
là aussi faisons attention parce que je
crois qu'un des problèmes que nous avons
dans cette histoire là c'est qu'ils à
l'islamisme et l'islam en sachant que
l'islam d'ailleurs on le nom l'eau
regarde comme si c'était un bloc alors
que c'est bien qu'il ya une
différenciation énorme au sein de mêmes
tons donc moi je pense que plutôt le
problème que nous avons un des problèmes
c'est peut être déjà commencé par
définir
exactement ce qui est cette radicalité
radicalité religieuse de cette religion
qui conduit au terrorisme parce que
sinon on mélange beaucoup de choses je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup de confusion et
tout le monde se trouve dans un débat
très crispé voilà ce que vous dire je
pense qu'il est important qu'on omet le
monde moi je ne sais pas quel terme mais
je pense que c'est une radicalité de la
religion musulmane
il faudrait trouver un autre terme que
l'islamisme je crois que ce serait
beaucoup plus intéressant à mon sens par
ses professeurs si vous pouvez répondre
de façon synthétique car ce que nous
avons après trois collègues encore je
réponds à madame le sénateur moi je
partage totalement votre votre votre vos
propos couper le cordon ombilical
carrément entre ce que vous avez si bien
dire l'islam des consulats et mais fort
de constater que ce n'est pas le cas
encore en temps réel et encore des
protocoles qui continue donc je m'en
réjouis que vous donc représentant de la
république que vous avez fortement
préconisée ça pour que soit que ça passe
à l'acte qu'on passe à l'acte alors
comment former des laits les imams ou
ceux qui dirigent ben ayed par
l'université rien n'empêche dans le
cadre des formations ou de la réforme
lmd d'adosser un module ou un master de
formation spécifique dans universités
que n'appartient pas de cibler mes
universités haddock qui pourra former
ces gens là selon un cahier des charges
extrêmement contraignant et cela en
protocole qui tient en fil rouge la
laïcité
il n'y a aucun problème de faisabilité
c'est une décision qui m'appartient pas
mais je veux dire elle est sur plan
technique il est possible de faire de
l'islamologie quand je les rappeler tout
à l'heure ils n'ont pas l'histoire de
l'islam où le culte de l'islam et de
l'islamologie en tant que
le segment de l'histoire de l'humanité
alors pour ce que dit monsieur le
sénateur donc je pense que la radicalité
et les intrinsèque monsieur l'islam si
vous reveniez vert depuis ses origines
l'islam est basée sur la confiance la
conflictuelle it et c'est pas une raison
religion apaisé dire que c'est quoi la
différence entre islam et islamisme
ça c'est ce sont des cd jeux de mots
contextualiser décontextualisés mais en
réalité l'islam mais quoi est terminée
nous sommes dans un islam de la discorde
de la fitna cet islam qui porte en lui
même le germe de la conflictualité et de
la violence d'ailleurs pas propre à la
france vous voyez que sur les l'ensemble
des pays musulmans sont dans les trois
quarts sont tous impacté par la violence
idéologique de l'islam radical islam
radical
alors moi je n'ai pas dit
les musulmans radicaux je parlais
d'islamistes et j'entends par islamistes
quelqu'un qui à qui un bébé d'une
idéologie qui refuse trois ou quatre
valeurs cardinales que vous avez si bien
cité la laïcité d'égalité en femmes qui
sont dans la logique de la prévalence de
la fatwa sur la loi et qui sont dans une
logique de la tutelle de l'homme sur la
femme
il faut qu'on a dit ça je pense pas que
qui puisse qu'on peut dire qu'il n'ya
pas de l'islamisme c'est à l'islamisme
d'accord on va peut-être juste seconde
dire que moi j'ai le temps je dis juste
que je pense qu'il serait bon de ne pas
partir du mot islam pour faire un
intégrisme d'avoir un autre terre je
sois bien clair j'ai ouï mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui la société imposer le mot
islamiste donc on se débat avec ce terme
je vais donner la parole à catherine
troendlé puis ensuite à alain cazabonne
catherine
voilà merci de votre présentation
j'ai une petite question concernant les
associations nous avons mené de front
avec madame esther benbassa un travail
sur ce que nous avons appelé non pas la
déradicalisation mais le désendettement
et le décembre également des personnes
radicaliser vous avez fait quelque 2
accroche concernant les associations et
moi je souhaitais avoir par rapport au
temps passé de des conclusions de notre
rapport à aujourd'hui
quel regard vous portez vous sur les
associations aujourd'hui qui sont agréés
les associations pour lesquelles nous
avons tenu à ce qu'elle soit elle même
tenu un cahier des charges national par
rapport à la déclinaison de leur prise
en charge deux de ces personnes tout
particulièrement les jeunes radicaliser
est-ce que vous même vous avez porté un
regard particulier sur ces associations
qui aujourd'hui me semble moins soumises
aux dérives qu'elles ne l'étaient encore
ya deux ans mais ses professeurs nous
allons écouter d'abord la question
d'alain cazabonne
bonjour assure j'avais peine question
mais beaucoup ont déjà été évoqués ok me
restait juste une remarque lorsque vous
avez vos clés le lit modification de nos
relations avec des pays comme le qatar
ou comme l'arabie saoudite
pardonnez moi de vous dire c'est presque
un voeu pieux c'est un jeu de mots parce
que quand il ya les marchés les armes à
côté c'est comme si elle allait en chine
leur dire il faut respecter les droits
de l'homme
la question ne porte plus sur ma faim
qui était avec l'histoire la traduction
des prêches
entre l'arabe et le français parce que
c'est une véritable difficulté
je rejoins la question nathalie de lot
qu'est ce qui va se passer lorsque tout
ça se passera sur internet
professeur si vous voulez bien répondre
merci tout d'abord je pense que
certaines associations qui travaillent
sur le processus de des doctrines
mandeau de déradicalisation font pas
partie des critiques que j'ai formulées
à l'égard des associations culturelles
territorialisée dans les zones urbaines
sensibles etc
donc je préfère je pense que c'est une
chance à prendre en compte deuxièmement
je pense que c'est ils ont commencé à
réellement à vay un impact très
important mais ce sont des gens qui ont
ce qu'ils ciblent qui ont ciblé un
public était déjà tracé par les services
de renseignement au tracé par la cnps
après le centre national d'assistance
est alors moi je parle de la société
dans sa globalité sur le concept comment
on peut déconstruire le concept ça ne
malheureusement ça doit c'est un travail
d'universitaire deux spécialistes et
c'est un travail qui demande beaucoup de
temps parce que il faut ré expliquer à
l'ensemble de ces jeunes ce que c'est
comme l'a dit monsieur zh que c'est
l'islam est pas l'islamiste travaillait
aussi on un peu plus en amont sur la
déconstruction des mythes de
prêt-à-penser de j'allais dire de 2,2
caricature de cette religion mais il
faut continuer à soutenir ces
associations qui soustrait des individus
de cette radicalisation
je n'ai pas travaillé de manière très
importante sur ces choses là mais je
crois que au début quand j'ai eu à
travailler à consulter le travail de
madame dounia bouzar pour ne pas la
citer ou de monsieur patrick amoyel j'ai
senti que dans ce travail qui à de
l'improvisation de l'opportunisme et de
l'exploitation de la détresse de l'état
pour ce qui est monsieur le sénateur
vous avez parlé de deux du vieux que moi
je suis à l'université je suis pas un
politique donc je fais pas de politique
d'ailleurs non plus je je considère que
bien sûr ils vont contourner par
internet c'est déjà fait d'ailleurs
qu'ils ont des sites mais le il faut que
la france envoie un message clair c'est
un message politique pour leur dire il
faut arrêter de déverser si vous aurez
le plaisir le temps de lire mon ouvrage
les 60 prédicateur sur lesquels j'ai
travaillé c'était pas dans l'absolu
selon un canevas qu'est ce qu'il pense
du terrorisme qu'est ce qu'ils pensent
de la radicalisation en france qu'est ce
qu'il pense de la sphère charlie qu'est
ce qu'il pense de la liberté de poser
des questions précises et à toutes ces
questions et son il y a des réponses
extrêmement inquiétante
ce sont des gens qui combattent la
france il faudra assumer cette réalité
donc il n'est pas interdit
via les réseaux diplomatiques au moins à
ces prédicateurs de respecter notre
souveraineté et de ne pas dresser les
citoyens contre leur pays
c'est tout ce que je voulais dire
comment il faut faire je ne sais pas je
sais qu'il ya des intérêts qui a des qui
à la raison d'état je sais que mon
discours peut-être peut atteindre le
plafond de verre parce que je touche à
des choses qui me dépassent
mais c'est une réalité qu'il faut
prendre très au sérieux qu'il faut tenir
compte de cette réalité que pourquoi ces
prêcheurs n'attaque pas des pays comme
l'angleterre comme l'espagne comme les
tailles et pourquoi c'est spécifique à
la france
pardon
alors nous allons continuer avec nos
collègues une souris et ensuite
eliane assassi la présidente une une
question rapide parce que là déjà trouvé
un certain nombre de réponses sur les
lieux de radicalisation vous l'avez dit
sont plus vraisemblablement les mosquées
qui aujourd'hui sont les principaux
lieux de radicalisation parce que pour
l'essentiel ils sont contrôlés mais
plutôt les associations et les salles de
prière vous n'avez pas parlé beaucoup de
la propagande sur internet qui je pense
est un véritable phénomène également et
donc ma question était simple c'est
selon vous quels sont les moyens de
contrôle aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
notre société démocratique de l'état
français vis à vis tu de ces lieux et et
cette propagation
merci monsieur je vais rapide va écouter
la question des liens nasa si on a
commencé par des vagues de 2 va finir
présidence est très rapide
je visais une page du journal le monde
du 2 daté d'aujourd'hui métier paru hier
ou lis un article sur la rencontre du
ministre de l'intérieur avec les
préfèrent aux et au cours de laquelle il
a dit sa volonté de lutter à la fois
contre l'islamisme et contre le
communautarisme et les fêtes et a donc
de la loi sur la sécurité intérieure que
je n'ai pas voter personnellement mais
qui permet la fermeture de lieux de
culte donc il y aurait 12 mosquée qui
auraient été fermés
quatre écoles neuf associations et 120
débits de boissons mais dans le même
temps me de l'intérieur dit qu'il n'a
pas beaucoup de doute y nouveau dit-il
pour appuyer son offensive
car selon lui ce combat doit se faire
dans le cadre des lois prévu par la
république
je voulais simplement mais ce professeur
avoir votre avis sur ce sujet
précisément
je vous remercie ses processeurs alors
je vais je vais répondre monsieur me
poser la question sur les la fermeture
des sites
je pense que les autorités de l'état ont
déjà fermé plusieurs sites bloqué
plusieurs sites
mais ce qu'on doit faire aussi comme
travail d'investigation très important
est peut-être je n'ai pas dit parce que
c'est je pense que tu dois te conseille
le travail surtout en dons dans
l'administration pénitentiaire parce que
c'est là aussi où il ya le véritable
héros de la radicalisation
mais sur internet c'est là nous ne
pouvons pas censurer une semaine
démocratie mais le chalet je l'avais dit
tout à l'heure
produire du contre-discours produire du
contre-discours contrecarrer tous ces
prédicateurs a lesser leur terrain
idéologique déconstruire leur adn
intellectuelle et avec un argumentaire
un peu on n'est qu' on ne peut on ne
peut gagner la bataille que sur le plan
deux intellectuels ses arguments contre
arguments déconstruire des des processus
de pensée déconstruire des fausses
réalités démystifier les choses je pense
que c'est possible et certains états ont
commencé à le faire
la belgique pour ne pas la citer
commencez donc à à à procéder par le
travail des spécialistes via des tic
tank à déconstruire des paradigmes des
dogmes pour pouvoir les injecter ou les
transformer en cursus scolaire pour
rééduquer toute une génération
c'est un travail peut-être
donnera pas ses fruits maintenant mais
c'est peut-être vaut mieux au moins le
lancer ou d'y réfléchir en tout cas pour
ce qui est de de la lutte contre contre
d'autres madame avait parlé que c'était
peu je pense qu'il y a quand même
beaucoup de salles qu'il faut faire mais
moi je ne peux pas vous parler beaucoup
parce que là je reprends mon ancienne à
casquette de chargé de mission au
ministère de l'intérieur il ya quand
même une hiérarchie lisation en fait tu
parles ministère sur un certain nombre
de mosquées qui doivent normalement être
fermé la question n'est pas juridique la
question des politiques et moi dès qu'il
souhaitait y as politique ça je n'ai pas
d'avis là dessus mais en a les preuves
on a tout à toute une littérature
produite par les services de
renseignement et r&d départementaux qui
propose aux préconise la fermeture d'un
certain nombre de deux mosquées ou deux
salles de prière j'assiste beaucoup de
salles de prière et non pas de mosquée
merci professeur je pense qu'il faut
mieux contrôler que fermer parce que
sinon ce sont des prétextes de
radicalisation mais ça c'est aussi en
débat je propose que notre rapporteur
pose encore une dernière question avant
de conclure cette hausse était pour
rebondir se souviennent autres collègues
sur les fermetures
moi je pense qu'il vaut mieux fermer que
quand il ya des doutes que voilà inverse
sauf qu'aujourd'hui
clairement non mais clermont c'était
pour vous donner ma non c'était pour
vous donner mon sentiment c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une façon on ferme
en général pour deux raisons des
problèmes de sécurité ou d'infractions
au code de l'urbanisme donc on voit bien
les messages de salonique et quand même
l'université musulmane qui forme voilà
on peut se poser des questions sur cette
université qui a quand même bien à deux
en france on a une qui a été fermé
samedi
vendredi ou jeudi dernier par le train
fait uniquement pour elle le problème de
sécurité
alors qu'on sait bien que ce n'était pas
l'essentiel de la question
aujourd'hui on a deux biais la sécurité
et l infraction au code de l'urbanisme
on n'a rien d'autre donc quand on a des
inquiétudes et des doutes
sur ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de ces
lieux d'un pour l'instant on n'a pas de
contexte on n'a pas de textes qui nous
permet de faire mais clairement donc
c'est aussi peut-être à nous aujourd'hui
dans le cadre de cette commission
denquête de réfléchir à d'autres leviers
pour fermer ces lieux qui sont
effectivement des lieu de bouillonnement
anti républicain j'ai envie de dire donc
voilà si tu es ce que je voulais dire
par rapport à la fermeture de ces lieux
qui n'est effectivement pas si simple à
mener et à faire voilà donc et je
rebondis sur ces salles de prière qui
effectivement ne sont contrôlés par
personne et dans lesquels effectivement
la plupart des prêches sont contrôlés
par personne faut quand même juste le
dire
voilà voilà ce que je veux dire je pense
qu on a fait oui allez-y c'est juste une
dernière chose par rapport à cette
question je vous en remercie d'avoir
pris cette position qui est clair et net
c'est que dans beaucoup de pays qui sont
musulmans qui sont pas laïques
donc l'état contrôle le prêche par deux
procédés copie intégrale du prêche remis
au ministère de tutelle et copie au
ministère de l'intérieur deux mètres de
la vidéosurveillance pour enregistrer
tout ce qui se passe dans une mosquée
c'est les gens qui sont ici sont
honnêtes ils ont rien à se reprocher il
accepte le processus or dans beaucoup
dans beaucoup de salles de prière ils
ont refusé par don de mettre en place
des salles des pas des caméras de
vidéosurveillance c'est qu'il ya quelque
chose qui ne va pas parfait merci en
tout cas professeur vous êtes échange
très intéressant
nous allons clore cette audition voilà
pour cette audition qui inaugure donc
les travaux de la commission d' enquête
sur la radicalisation islamiste
une commission lancée à la demande dlr à
la suite notamment de l'attentât de la
préfecture de paris
l'objectif de cette commission denquête
faire l'état des lieux des problèmes de
radicalisation sur le territoire et voir
sur les réponses des autorités publiques
sont à la hauteur
rappelons que ces travaux sont lancés
dans un climat un petit peu polémique à
gauche certains craignent déjà les
amalgames pour la communauté musulmane
ce travail s'inscrit également dans la
ligne
et des très nombreux travaux consacrés
au djihadisme al islam à la lutte contre
le terrorisme par le sénat depuis
maintenant cinq ans vous pouvez toujours
voir et revoir toutes les auditions sur
notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée à tous sur les
chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]